post-quantum cryptographic standards the
expansion of the ibm business automation
portfolio and ibm's inclusion in three
recent analyst reports all on this
episode of ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
to start things off this week let's talk
about how you can protect yourself from
attacks by quantum computers in the
future i know i know it sounds like
something out of a sci-fi movie but i'm
talking about quantum safe cryptography
back in july the u.s national institute
of standards and technology selected the
first group of cryptographic tools that
are designed to withstand attacks posed
by quantum computers that will be
created in the future
the four selected cryptographic
algorithms will become part of nist's
post-quantum cryptographic standard and
ibm was involved in the development of
three of the four standards
the algorithms are designed for two main
tasks public key encapsulation and
digital signatures
now it would take a lot more time and
i'd probably need a few more degrees to
completely explain these cryptographic
tasks here but to just focus on the
basics of one digital signatures are
used for identity authentication and
non-repudiation
now adopting quantum state cryptography
at scale will be a decades-long process
but the new schemes are entering the
market in different products and
services offered by ibm and others
in particular the crypto express 8s
hardware security module which is
available as a feature of the z16
platform allows application developers
to use the new quantum safe algorithms
this means that you can generate
crystals dilithium digital signatures
with z16
so all that to say
ibm z16 positions you to begin using
quantum safe cryptography along with
classical cryptography as you start
modernizing existing applications and
building new ones
to learn more about this fascinating
topic check out the link i've got in the
description of this post
next up ibm is expanding its business
automation portfolio to include two new
open source offerings ibm process
automation manager open edition and ibm
decision manager open edition
these offerings which were previously
delivered by red hat complement our
current low code no code platform to
address it-centric build-your-own use
cases
they allow us to deliver intelligent
business automation capabilities for
workflow and decision management that
meet the needs of all kinds of
organizations
we're really excited about these
offerings because they provide a great
opportunity to extend our long-standing
commitment to open source to learn more
about these new offerings hit the link
below
to wrap things up today i'm proud to
announce that ibm was named a leader in
three recent analyst reports that
evaluate rpa and intelligent automation
service providers these types of analyst
reports can help potential customers
compare and evaluate providers as they
look to adopt intelligent automation
solutions
and based on the extensive work we've
been doing in the field it's no
coincidence that ibm was named a leader
in all three
the three reports are the forester wave
for robotic process automation services
idc marketscape worldwide intelligent
automation services 2022 vendor
assessment and everest group's
intelligent process automation solution
provider compendium 2022
to see some of the report highlights or
download the whole thing check out the
link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now